so continuing our series on comic book
concepts since we've spent so much time
covering marvel comics
i want to switch things up a bit and
focus on some stuff from dc
beginning with a story of how superman
became a nazi
originally appearing in multiversity
mastermind number one
i want to take a step back and explore
the idea of the multiversity concept
and what it represents in dc comics so
for those of you who have not seen my
video on dc's multiverse which you'll
find in the description
while the history of dc's crises can be
really overwhelming
the general idea went something like
this dc invented their multiverse in
but over the course of around 20 years
they grew to be unmanageable and
confusing to new readers
and so in 1985 dc eliminated the
multiverse with crisis on infinite
earths
where this would remain the standard for
around another 20 years in 2005
dc brought the multiverse back with
infinite crisis although the heroes
didn't know about it
but this changed at the conclusion of
final crisis when the heroes became
aware that the multiverse had been
reborn
following this writer grant morrison
began to work on multiversity
which was designed to provide a series
of one-shot comics running over the
different alternate realities in the dc
multiverse
where these different realities were
intended to cover the pre new 52
multiverse
when dc began the process of planning
their line-wide reboot the multiversity
line of stories was remolded to reflect
the multiverse as it existed
following the launch of the new 52 in
2011.
now regarding the story of how superman
became a nazi this particular scenario
unfolded with the masterman one shot
opening up with hitler using the
restroom his constitution was
interrupted with the appearance of a
subordinate
informing him that his attention is
needed now something i'd like to draw
your attention to
is that hitler is actually reading a
comic book of superman fighting hitler
the reason why this little tidbit is
interesting is because it's one of the
many scenarios grant morrison uses to
provide a kind of meta commentary
and that multiversity focused on the
idea that to each reality
the various stories that exist in
literature are a universe that they're
simply not aware of
what i mean here is that where earth 10
is a reality where the germans won world
war ii
the comic adolf hitler is reading
reflects a reality where this didn't
happen
due to superman defeating hitler again
while this isn't wildly important it's
suddenly just one of those little
fun moments that appear in the
multiversity line of stories
but the urgent message being provided by
the subordinate indicates that a
weapon's been found of such a degree
that it guarantees germany's victory
over the allied powers
transitioning to the ship of superman
following its crash landing in the
sudetenland the vessel was discovered by
an unarmed german couple
who informed the authorities to
sidetrack for a second the sudan land
was a region between germany and the
czech republic
and because it largely consisted of
german people hitler viewed its
occupation as germany retaking its rifle
territories
returning the country to greatness
crossing into the sudetenland in march
of 1938
this move was considered to be the
catalyst which led to the invasion of
poland and the official start of world
war
ii but regarding this particular story
where the vessel is
extremely small and viewed by hitler as
not being large enough to house a
full-grown adult
his scientists revealed that hitler's
correct and that the vessel contained an
infant child
now much like the superman that we know
today this version was bulletproof
as it was shown when the ss officers
began shooting at the child when their
bullets bounced off
but something that i want to talk about
here for a second is what grant morrison
doesn't say
one of the most well-known aspects of
the nazi war machine were the varying
experiments on humans
while these range from bone muscle and
nerve transplants to sewing twins
together in an attempt to create
conjoined twins
where morrison doesn't address these
experiments directly what he does tell
us is that the act of the soldier
shooting superman is designed to
demonstrate that the child's bulletproof
meaning that sometime after his
discovery but before being shown to
hitler
the soldiers had shot the child in an
experiment to see if it was human or not
following this where hitler views
superman as a kind of messiah from the
future nicknaming him the man of
tomorrow
morrison also provides us with a brief
overview of the events of world war
ii and that over the course of the next
17 years superman had been provided a
german superhero name of overman
and had fought along the german lines
leading the axis powers to north america
in 1956 where they successfully managed
to take over washington dc
in addition to this the different forms
of literature in america including
comics designed to mirror the early
captain america comics
are deemed propaganda and burn
accordingly the lincoln monuments
destroyed the washington monument is
turned into a symbol of nazi germany
and the various flags around the capital
are replaced with swastikas
now from here we jump forward around 60
years later to a nightmare involving the
death of a character named overgirl
alongside this universe's versions of
batman the flash aquaman and hawkman
among others
waking up in the company of a woman
named lena in truth she's actually
designed to be a stand-in for lois lane
and a love interest for superman that
will last throughout the entire course
of the story
but the conversation between the two
actually provides us some valuable
insight into the events
as they've unfolded so far what we're
told is that in this reality instead of
being named clark
over man is named carl in addition to
this the dream of overman involves
something akin to a decrepit house with
eyes on the inside
now i'd like you to keep this in the
back of your mind since it will serve as
a foreshadow of the end of the comic
but as the two continue to talk we're
told that this dream has been recurring
for years
and seems to be tied into both the
element of insurgents and the death of
overgirl
while both of these concepts will be
expanded on as we transition throughout
the story
while attending the funeral of overgirl
the eternal flame lit in her memory is
blown out with the appearance of uncle
sam
alongside the human bomb now to
sidetrack for a second the human bomb
was a character named roy lincoln and
first appeared in police comics number
one
under the banner of quality comics
originally gaining his abilities by
consuming a chemical called 27qrx
roy lincoln developed the ability to
create explosions by touching objects
with the most powerful explosions
generated
when touching his hands as a result roy
began to wear a suit contained a fibro
wax
only removing the gloves in order to
cause explosions more quality comics
went into bankruptcy following the
collapse of interest in superhero comics
during the late 1940s
in 1956 dc acquired the rights to the
human bomb along with several other
golden age creations from other
publishers
while these characters remain
unpublished for almost 20 years in 1973
following the successful relaunch of
shazam
dc reintroduced human bomb along with
several other characters
including uncle sam all of whom operated
within the pre-crisis earth x reality
where the nazis had taken control of the
world
becoming part of a group called the
freedom fighters in essence what grant
morrison is doing here is taking the
earth x idea
reworking it and applying it to the
multiversity landscape
this becomes apparent when we transition
to a discussion between overman and this
reality's version
of the justice league called the new
reichsman residing within a satellite
called the eagles nest
what's really interesting about this
discussion is that it's kind of a meta
commentary by morrison regarding the
concept of good and evil
what i mean here is that historically
there's truth to the statement that
history is written by the victor
and that where overman argues that these
insurgent attacks are a byproduct of
their previous actions when the nazis
were seizing power
this reality's version of batman called
leather wings addresses over man's
feelings of viewing their past
in a shameful light by stating that he's
not ashamed of anything from their past
to overman though as far as he was
concerned he was there throughout the
entire war
during which time the nazis had engaged
in heinous acts of torture and
intolerance
towards anyone they deemed to be
inferior in addition to this the
atlanteans led by underwater man and the
amazonians led by brunhild
were only spared destruction due to the
nazis believing that they were the
source of the aryan race owing to the
atlanteans blonde hair and blue eyes
and the amazonians being all white women
and so what morrison's doing here is
using a concept called the categorical
imperative
established by emanuel khan in his book
a critique of pure reason
the categorical imperative argued that
an act is moral if and only if
anyone can engage in that act tying this
into the story the scenario as is
presented here
is that the nazis had seized power
killed off different races from around
the world
eliminated english as an acceptable
language and replaced it with german
which created insurgents who look to
cast off control of the nazis
and the influence of the new reichsman
something to also take note of here is
that while overman was raised under the
hands of hitler and oversaw the nazis
seizing control of the world
instead of becoming an evil dictator
continuing hitler's views of intolerance
instead overman has mixed feelings about
the current state of the world
and the actions of the nazis during his
conversation with brunhild he argues
that because of humanity's past and the
atrocities committed by the nazis
it seems reasonable to believe that much
like any system or oppressive authority
somewhere along the line that very
authority will engineer its own defeat
by creating an enemy for itself by
shifting our focus to the former new
york city
we pick up with the real uncle sam who
functions as the leader of the freedom
fighters
now again much like the human bomb uncle
sam was a hero published by quality
comics
as the spirit of a patriotic soldier
killed during the revolutionary war
who went on to inhabit bodies of various
people in order to fight on behalf of
america
however this origin was retconned when
uncle sam was reintroduced alongside
human bomb
in the 1970s under this new origin uncle
sam was now the spirit of america
who was confined to a talisman and would
merge with a dying patriot
in the final days of their life to this
end where morrison doesn't tell us who
this man
is instead he leaves things largely
ambiguous by indirectly stating
that somewhere along the line following
the onset of world war ii
uncle sam had taken control of a dying
patriots body in an effort to hold off
the nazi invasion but was ultimately
unsuccessful
most likely due to the involvement of
overman but transitioning to an
interview with this reality's jimmy
olsen who works as the face of the nazi
news agency
while most of the interview deals with
the rising insurgency attacks by uncle
sam and the freedom fighters
where overman does say that he and the
reichsmen are on the way to eliminating
the freedom fighters in their entirety
the discussion begins to shift its focus
to overman's anti-nazi views
now one of the reasons why i love this
part of the story so much is that it
focus on the idea of what overman
represents
in relation to superman in his view the
dc universe
is more along the lines of an animating
consciousness and that the dc
characters are sentient themselves even
if this is on a rudimentary level
the idea is that if the multiverse
exists it's entirely possible that on a
subconscious level
the various writers of the comic book
industry are quite literally crafting
stories
that provide us with views of alternate
realities that may exist
to this end while superman changes based
on these different universes ranging
from this story where he operates as a
nazi
to red sun where he was raised by the
russians in the end the goal of superman
is always altruistic but is based on the
context of the reality that he's in
what i mean here is that where red son
saw superman implementing mind control
on humanity
and this version of superman fights
against the freedom fighters in the end
their motivations lie in their desire to
protect the citizens of the world
and uphold the righteousness of their
ideologies while this may seem backwards
the point morrison is making here
is that we only view this version of
superman as evil based on the world that
he lives in
and the status he upholds instead of
making our determination on him as a
character
now from here we jump to the events
following the interview and the
realization that the death of overgirl
has brought on a kind of festival of
sorts where the city of metropolis
mourns her death
for 10 days picking up with leather
wings and underwater man
we also discover that there's talk of an
insider from the reichsmen
feeding information to the freedom
fighters helping them to subvert the
efforts of the reichsman and
re-establish freedom within america for
leatherwings much like batman from the
main continuity
his decisions are governed largely by
reason and logic as opposed to emotion
as a result where overman had stated
that he didn't see anything wrong with
the physiology of human bomb
while he doesn't say it the idea of
leather wings is that overman is the
mole within their ranks
feeding information to the freedom
fighters in an effort to indirectly cast
off control of the nazis
however before this idea can be expanded
on any further
human bomb emerges after having become
free of his minds
where he detonates and destroys a
portion of the satellite
at the same time the voice of uncle sam
emerges in the middle of a play
during the morning festival for overgirl
claiming that the world of the nazis is
corrupt
and will be brought down by uncle sam
and his forces with the explosions of
the satellite have drawn the attention
of overman
where the audience focuses on uncle
sam's projection and the freedom
fighters invading the theater
overman races to stop the satellite from
crashing into the earth
while he does the best that he can
because the past 98 years has seen a
reduction in his strength
from their peak in his youth overman
isn't able to keep the satellite from
crashing in a metropolis
leading to the city's complete
destruction and the death of millions
and so as the story comes to an end
after he emerges from the wreckage
overman is revealed to be the only
survivor of metropolis with the
destruction of the city signaling the
end of the nazi regime
and the start of the freedom fighters
returning north america to its former
state prior to the nazis taking over
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and post a
comment down below
and let me know what do you like more
the versions of superman that are the
classical versions where he's a good guy
or the versions of superman where he's a
bad guy and i will catch you guys later
peace
you